hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter one of
his monologue so right from the very
start and some is going to provide us
with what he takes to be a rational
proof and the argument for the existence
of God God understood as the supreme
being but also in this chapter as the
supreme goodness and a supreme greatness
something that he's also going to talk a
bit about in chapter 2 so what we'll
talk about just how he conceptualizes
that at the very end of this video when
we turn to chapter 2 we want to look at
here is the argument that an sum is
making in Chapter 1 which has to do with
the notion of goodness you know where
goodness comes from now it's very
important that you keep it in mind the
two background assumptions that I've
talked about in other core concept
videos in again so-and-so is adopting a
platanus perspective so he does in fact
hold to a doctrine of participation
which is going to play a role here he
also holds to a doctrine of degrees of
being which also plays a role here
although in unless it's explicitly so he
starts out by saying look we know
experience that there is a multiplicity
of good things how do we know that any
sense
you know we return our mind towards
investigating the source of the goodness
of those things that we desire because
we judge that their their good what do
we in fact see there's countless Goods
whose great diversity we experience both
through our bodily senses you know like
drinking coffee or laying around and
relaxing or you know seeing an
interesting spectacle Andy says also
through the reasoning of our mind you
know like what for example we're told we
should take some bitter medicine and
we're like that doesn't sound very good
to me but I'd rather not be sick so I
think I'll take the medicine that's
through the reasoning of our our mind
right and so we encounter this this vast
plurality this multiplicity this
diversity of goods and the question then
that raises itself for us is well is
there something that actually makes
these goods good and in some is going to
answer yes there is an indeed one thing
through which all of these goods are
good I'm not putting that at this point
in the argument because we we want to
see you know sort of the objections that
could be made against then how he deals
with those objections so we're going to
come back to that in just a moment but I
wanted to signal that he noticed that
there is a multiplicity as well of
reasons or is he saying things or you
might say the wine that makes things
good and he's got some interesting
examples here that are well worth
considering he says a horse if we want
to call a horse good we could pick other
things besides the horse and we can pick
other qualities besides this but you get
the general idea
a horse is called good through one thing
because it's strong well the horse is
called good through another because it's
fast strength fastness not the same
thing right you can have a very big
strong
a horse like a Clydesdale and they can
pull the beer wagon or whatever it's
supposed to do right pull the plow and
it can be extremely strong but not
particularly fast you can have a race
horse they can take a lot but it can't
pull the plow to save its life its
benefactor can't really go much of you
know adding any pigs without some really
super light almost childlike jockey on
its back and a grown man like myself
would slow it down and probably hurt it
these are different things so a horse
that is strong and fast appears to be
good through two different things
strength and speed right he makes it the
problem even more complex he says why
don't we consider a robber who also is
strong and fast to be a good robber
because of his strength and his
quickness we actually say he's bad
because of that because it makes it
easier for him to break into our houses
and steals our stuff and get away right
so it's not those things on their own
that make you know everything good not
everything that is fast is good not
everything that is strong is necessarily
good so what actually does make things
good the anselm is not train provide you
with a full ethical theory at this point
so you know don't write it in comments
that oh well there's other reasons why
things can be good he's trying to make
an argument here that is is going to
lead somewhere else he's got a whole
other set of discussions about the
nature of goodness in other places he
goes on and they says nothing is
ordinarily considered good except either
one of two things either because of some
usefulness right in Latin that's
utilities house and he's been talking
about this in other places as the
beneficial the the commode 'im that
which is is conducive to us here he
gives the example of a health and those
things that conduce to health right or
that is one type of goodness or because
of something
transit value and this is a way to try
to translate a term that the anselm is
using Honus bottom bonus taxes you know
finesse toss it's it's hard to get
across it does mean something like that
which has now you for its own sake that
we get an honesty from that that term is
attributes of terminus used to translate
another equally difficult to translate
great term the Kowloon meaning that
which is you know attractive beautiful
honorable pleasing but not just not
merely pleasing but pleasing because
it's got an intrinsic goodness trip so
in any case something that has intrinsic
value and here he gives the example of
beauty and things that contribute to
beauty so these are two important ways
for things very basic ways for things to
be good so the robber is not good even
though the robber is strong and fast
because the robber is the opposite of
useful the robber is actually harmful to
other people and also you know if you
want to get down to it to the robber him
or herself right so the question that we
can ask that you notice what we've been
doing is sort of circling in a few
things that out of this multiplicity
that make good things good the question
then is is there one thing that we can
trace all of these back to the Anselm
says that there must be some good
through which all the good things are
good
not just good in the sense of usefulness
or intrinsic goodness but good per se
all goodness must ultimately refer to
and trace back to a goodness a unity of
goodness that makes everything else pit
so he says for example a little bit
earlier here we go
to all the more willing to pay attention
it's clear and quite certain all things
whatsoever that are said to be more or
less equally a certain way as compared
to each other sent through something
that has not understood as different but
rather the same and different things
there's that that doctrine of
participation and then he says it's
certain that all goods in if they're
compared to each other are either
equally or unequally good so it must be
that they're good through something that
is understood to be the same and diverse
things even though it seems that
sometimes different goods are said to be
good as for different things so when
were considering the multiplicity of
goods we have some general unity that we
trace them back to and then he goes on
he says you know it must be the case of
all useful or intrinsically valuable
things if they are genuinely good and
he's saying intrinsically valuable
things are in fact genuinely good useful
things could be good could also not be
good right if they're good they must be
good through that very same thing
whatever it is through which all goods
must be or exist so however you want to
divide up goodness in your general
categories whether you want to use like
an Aristotelian differentiation between
the good as Pleasant the good as useful
other good as you know good in itself
the Kallang whether you want to adopt
some other thing and some can still say
the same basic idea okay well what makes
all those kinds of good good
can we trace it back to something
central and he thinks that we can't now
this thing makes all other good things
good says who would doubt that this
thing through which all goods exist is
itself a great good now how great is it
he says can this good Hammett's being
through another this is where we're
getting to sort of the top of the ladder
you might say this is good thing
goodness itself through which all these
good things that we call good exist
through which they have their being as
good could that itself be dependent upon
something else not even necessarily
right up front for its goodness but for
its being the end song says no because
if that were to be the case then the
meaning which causes the good capital G
to exist would in fact be better than
the good they wouldn t because it's
productive of such a great good so
anyway there would be a greater good and
the good would be unequal to it and
that's not you know coherent to think
through so he says that's what leads us
to conclude that this good is supremely
good and what does he mean by Supremes
well he explains here supreme by the way
is a relative term says something is
supreme if it surpasses others in such a
way that nothing is equal to or more
excellent or better than it so what is
you know what is this good it's going to
be the supreme good that also means that
it is supremely great which is
technically when we get down to it the
same thing as being good as we'll see a
further video but does seem to be
something different from that so he goes
in and explains this he says it is
supremely good supremely great in other
words to premium on all existing things
he's got that that he's demonstrated
there is a supreme good that is what
what the Anselm considers God to be so
this is an argument for the existence of
God now chanting - like I promised we're
going to go a little bit further and he
says you know we have something that is
supremely great since whatever great
things exist are great through some one
thing that is great through itself and
he goes on to explain well what do we
mean by great do we mean that like God
is the biggest thing of all he says no
we're not talking about bodily magnitude
in terms of greatness he says I mean
great in the sense that the greater
something is the better or worthier it
is yes for example
wisdom is great wisdom is not something
that you can easily quantify although
people like you know IQ test that's
actually measuring wisdom that's just
measuring a certain many respects
secondary aspect of intelligence but we
we are thinking about something that can
have a highest degree so wisdom is
something good to him the more that you
have of it the better it is to be that
way I think it says only what a
supremely good can be supremely great so
there must be something greatest and
best that is supreme among all existing
things again what is he attempting to do
here this is an argument for the
existence of God but it's an argument
based on the nature of goodness arguing
to a supreme goodness which would be God